do you think the rest of the world is
really that stupid no is he a crook
no of course it's not a [ __ ] and it's
gonna be rather uncomfortable for you
isn't it
no it's not at all uncomfortable we will
see who is less corrupted and who is
better managing and governing the
country
the tiny East European state of Moldova
has a new coalition government United it
seems only in its dislike of the
previous administration my guest this
week here in the capital kisser now is
Vladimir chebotar a vice president of
the outgoing Democratic Party and a
former justice minister with Moldova now
a byword for corruption is he ashamed of
his party's record in government
[Music]
Nadira chebotar ii welcome to conflict
zone i'm pleased to be here healthy
discussion your party lost the battle to
hold on to power but you deserve to lose
in a way didn't you because democracy
was increasingly undermined under your
watch and there was massive corruption
which you did very little about so you
deserved to go didn't you really it
depends how to look at that and i would
disagree with something related to the
corruptions but yes indeed i can say
that we have lots of critics related to
the democracy tendencies in republic of
lava though the democratic parties when
undertook while undertaking the mandate
and governance in 2016 they achieved a
lot in social and economical
performances the for example the
salaries increased in the public area by
70 percents the average salaries their
pensions last year you were sure in the
world that the democratic party was
implementing european standards at home
that's what you said in september yes
yeah Europe was telling a completely
different story about you the European
Parliament condemned what it called an
increasing backsliding on core values
related to democratic standards so much
for your European standards it also
added that Moldova was trapped by
oligarchic interests with the economic
and political power in the hands of a
small group of people exerting their
influence on Parliament the government
political parties state administration
police and judiciary in other words your
assurances about European standards were
worthless well that no I would disagree
with that because in my opinion this was
a political statement and we can have
different opinions because it has been
done by a political group it was based
on findings that they discovered when
they came here talks that they've been
having well as again did you see did he
show any evaluation or some some reports
regarding to that because I haven't seen
and everything that could be measured
has been measured with the significant
progresses but that I will it the view
of the EU the Council of Europe Freedom
House the UN the US State Department and
International OSCE bertelsmann
foundation there was remarkable
unanimity about the state of democracy
and corruption in this country from them
wasn't let me please explain otherwise
if you want to hear me because while I
would divide those two issues I would
divide the corruption and I would divide
the democracy why because while talking
about corruption since 2016 they were
the most progresses that ever have been
done in Republic of Moldova in fighting
corruption it was the first cases when
ministers the Prime Minister's and other
very high officials have been prosecuted
the u.s. code is elective justice now if
selectively just well one we're talking
about the ministers that were in our
government I wouldn't say that it was
selective because selective means then
when you are prosecuting all everyone
except your arms but it wasn't the case
and it also said you want the mind of
the processes the judicial processes
that's also led a view of the United
States well it was some Usha's well but
this is not related more than some
issues isn't it mr. Bertoni
no I again and there are difficulties in
judicial system of course there are but
while talking to corruption this was the
most fighting period in Republic of
Moldova that's why according to the
public perception corruption was the
first one ranked problem in 2016 and it
became the fifth one in 2019 due to the
efforts that have been put fighting that
in March
Washington's Human Rights report
effectively highlighted what all the
other international organizations have
been saying they highlighted torture in
your prisons arbitrary arrests and
detention by the authorities
restrictions on freedom of the media and
serious attacks on people who stood in
the way of your party especially lawyers
as one UN Special Rapporteur reported
lawyers faced politically motivated
criminal charges or were threatened each
time they defended people with opinions
dissenting from the authorities you
our justice minister and you signed off
on all this you were quite happy that
that should happen that these lawyers
should be threatened well you know in
Moldova is very fashionable to start
victimizing yourself and to start doing
politics while you have some criminal
cases on your side because for example
to do with the charges well you are
these exactly these exactly cases you
are referring to two cases one of them
is related to one attorney a woman that
has been committed a crime murder in
1990 1999 and the other one is another
lawyer
they were just referring to two cases
the two cases refer a referee I know
exactly the cases that they are
referring to and other cases this case
of lawyer rudenko who has committed
bribe and traffic of influence
before starting being the lawyer of one
of the people that pretending to be
politician so Lisa we are talking about
two cases all of them committed crimes
before starting coming into the public
area we have a lot of different cases to
go through mr. Shiva Terry why was the
international community so keen on
seeing you go on June the 14th the
United States basically said it was
pleased to see you go the State
Department spokesman said the u.s.
welcomes the Democratic Party's
announcement that is withdrawing from
government in favour of Prime Minister
primary Prime Minister Maya Sandow and
the coalition formed by the
democratically elected parliament the
fact is Washington couldn't wait to get
rid of you could it and more importantly
it wasn't going to lift a finger to save
you was it well no one should leaves any
fingers to save any politicians or the
others it was a coalition created that
were accepted at a final stage and we
transferred the powers of the governor's
it is good the people to have the
comparison of how the country can be
governed by once and by the others it's
good for us to give up willingly you
gave up national pressure you you even
got the constitutional court to strip
the president of his power so that new
elections could be called for cetera
didn't
if we are talking about that it's good
to have to see how the events evolved
since the 7of tuned and you'll see that
we cave the power in a peaceful manner
and we give it willingly and we made
these announcements for days before
transferring the power after trying to
get the constitutional court to step in
and call elections that's what you tried
to do oh it isn't try to step in any
Constitutional Court stuff like that
because on Monday already which was the
third day of that announcement of the
Constitutional Court we already took the
decision to transfer the power and on
Tuesday which was the fourth day what we
already announced that we are willing to
stay and to discuss how to transfer the
power peacefully who trusts any rulings
from your Constitutional Court these
days after you stuffed it with your own
people who trusts the Constitutional
Court here no the people trust the
Constitutional Court it doesn't trust
only the ones who doesn't don't like the
decisions of that in a report last year
the Bertelsmann Foundation said that the
current justice system including the
general prosecutor's office the supreme
court the supreme judiciary Council and
the National corruption Center were
largely subordinated to the oligarch
Vladimir the hot nuke who just happens
to be chairman of your Democratic Party
although you tell me he's just stood
down he's just announced that he's
leaving he just announced ahead but
that's not a great record
you were Justice Minister and you
allowed that kind of state I took I took
the management of the Minister of
Justice in 2015 at the end of the year
and at that time already
they were the statements that the state
is captured by the way second at that
time already
all the support of European Union in
that area has been refused or suspended
I had the conditionality to approve lots
of the reforms in a very short time and
I'd managed to do that in two years or
even less and it was accepted and
recognized now we we have a legislation
in the judiciary which is like a piece
of the art we have at last of a lot
of things to implement to work on
training the new judges which have been
renewed
we have almost 45 percent of the judge
the new ones which came into the system
but still we need to train them we need
to create uniform practices in that
respect and it cannot be done through
the night it was a crime done was to
stop the subordination to the chairman
of your partial attention I would
disagree to you to make the assessments
and the conclusions based only on the
statements of the parties that were on
the opposition at that time it's the
same thing today at two weeks time since
the government has been transferred to
the other parties I can say that
judiciary is subordinated to the new
government why very simple because it
was sufficient the new prime minister to
make some statements and the courts have
been changing their decisions
immediately through the night if this is
subordination then you have to accept
that they are subordinated to the new
government as well the leaders are
demanding obedience of the judiciary to
the authorities the last layer has been
enforced by your party using corrupt
practices business clan ties and
intimidation this was based on the fact
what they got it roll let's let's do
let's then discuss that let's let's
discuss that I just stated that the new
government and he took the control of
the judiciary and said it's not so if
they just made a statement but if they
make the statement that you have to
revise your decision and to decide like
that and the court immediately is doing
that what does means if not
subordination in your understanding in
in organs you watch on your watch mr.
Chabot I read the politicization of the
judiciary was an instrument which was
often used against mr. play hot nukes
rivals that was the conclusion of the
bertelsmann fan day
I from 2017 to 2018 thanks to your
efforts well the economic forum ranked
Moldova a hundred and thirty second out
of a hundred and thirty seven countries
as regards the Independence of the
judiciary are you proud of that record
that no of course am I no cuz I'm not
but at what they could say is that what
I can tell you is that when we took the
judiciary I took the judiciary it the
trust of the people in the judiciary was
seven percent and when I left my
position of the Ministry of Justice was
twenty five percents yes this is not
sufficient but in two years time to
increase this three times it's something
but the tendency on dependency party
chairmen no that's wrong well that's
what they said and that's wrong they
misunderstood fit that they just got it
wrong they made up the story is that
right is this what you're saying no I'm
not saying that I'm just saying that I'm
just saying that that we had a very poor
situation which is not very fantastic
today but it has registered a very good
improvements in that respect you you
deny any wrongdoing by the man I'm not
I'm just saying that it's not correct
just to state the wrongdoings but it is
correct to see how they the developments
and evolution of all of that what about
mr. plod look your colleague and Riaan
can do said in 2016 that he was made the
most hated man in the country because
people need to find somebody to blame
that's it he's blameless no we no one is
angel in Moldova
even the new governments even the old
government's even democratic parties the
members were not angels there's no on
his angel stake we are committing
mistake what's your crook
is he a crook yeah of course he's not a
crook well of course it's not a crook
it's a person that has insured a good
and efficient governance from the point
of view of the social infrastructure
problems yes maybe the party didn't
focus too much on democracy and maybe
the party didn't focus too much on
implementing some reforms in like Judy
for example but what he's done improving
the life of the people is done a lot and
even more than many other governance
putting together for the last previous
20 years when the new government came in
your party chief then mr. plod he fled
the country along with a business
partner in Elance or he was looking
perhaps for friends outside but he
didn't find any did he didn't find any
friendly again I would disagree with the
statement but because he left the
country only after transferring
peacefully their governance to the to
the opposition or to doubt I don't know
let's ask him I am NOT the neither the
interior ministry nor the border police
have a record of him leave the minister
the new Minister of Internal Affairs
made three different statements in just
one week and all of them conflicted
between each other so I would I wouldn't
pay too much price to the statements
that he made I understand that he's a
new minister but he's committing too
much mistaken smiie and is misleading
the public opinion in that race isn't
coming back you see it's over everyone's
had enough of your part let's ask him
let's ask him because your understanding
he's coming back my understanding is
that he's coming back as long or when
the security arrangements will be done
including hearing all over you refused
for a week to give up your officers
didn't use the officials you appointed
refused to obey the new Prime Minister's
wheels on the third day we already
announced so they accounting since 8th
of June we already announced that we are
willing to have discussions to transfer
the governance so I would disagree
4runners you put your supporters into
the square there could have been massive
violently right now because the transfer
should be peaceful and now should be
peaceful but it might not have been and
it was peaceful
I tried to get into the offices you
wouldn't men we know they didn't try and
to get into the offices some of them did
no no no we said none of them didn't try
to get into the offices they just made
some declarations
yes different it's good probably to pay
one week staying here in the
very hard times to understand the
situation no one tried and we made all
the announcements and invitations to
them to start talking and your time was
over what means the governess is over it
was over ornate of June yes yeah it's
over the new government has promised
there'll be no revenge I'm sure your
they already there they already saw your
relief to hear that no no no because
this is helping them with their
inquiries and sorry previous corruption
sorry because the harassment public
pressure and revenge already is there
many of the people already dismissed the
professional people which has no links
with the parties have been already
dismissed from their positions but if
you there is a people that I've been
carrying on different reforms and
different projects manage and funding by
our development partners they're put on
the spot it's gonna be rather
uncomfortable for you isn't it no it's
not at all uncomfortable because I see
many of the critics that they have been
done they'd already be coming to another
opinion because they they criticized not
knowing or not going into the details of
different projects and reforms but we'll
see what they will do and it's better to
judge about them and us in comparison
and we will see when how the the
salaries will rise we'll see how the
infrastructure projects will go on how
the collections of the budget will be
done and then we will see who is less
corrupted and who is better managing and
governing the country the challenge for
this government is to dismantle your
system of control over the courts and
the criminal investigation bodies isn't
it which you controlled basically and
which were loyal to your party chairmen
from 2016 transparency international
reported your main aim was to
concentrate your party's power within
the executive Criminal Investigation
bodies and courts it said are used by
this party as instil
to intimidate and make loyal political
rivals both its central and local level
so this practice is obvious particularly
in relation to local councillors and
mayor's it said that are blackmailed and
compelled to join the ruling party that
was you I'm very happy that you are
making reference to this specific report
because usually it takes time to prepare
a report and then to make it public and
so as it is dated 2016 it means exactly
that the older data's collected are in
the previous periods so I will in that
case I would just will restate that we
took the governance in 2016 only and of
course we recognize it was lots of the
problem in 2017 report 7017 report
imagine 16 I said from 2016 they said
your main aim was this was a report two
years ago when you were already in the
Justice Department and here let's come
to different mailing and compelling
mayors and local councillors to join the
ruling party again you know no official
claims in that respect have been done or
or submitted by anyone is just
opposition's statement and speculations
nothing has been confirmed in time do
you think do you think the rest of the
world is really that stupid
no no they don't work out what what
happened it just you were just do
anything just in order to understand the
situation is better to have a more
in-depth look at everything and having
at least while writing these reports at
least two opinions at least well we have
already quoted from the US State
Department from the European Parliament
from trans transparency international
from the OSCE one of the things that
came in to your area of control was were
the prisons mm-hmm
why did you allow a system of prison
hierarchy of convict hierarchy why did
you why did the gods collude with the
prisoners to control the system inside
the prison why well actually this is a
legacy which we're trying to fight and
to fix
and you need to do much with it whether
do we did a lot of things to do
definitely yes we did a lot to improve
the conditions in imprisonments and now
we have only two prisons that are in
very worst conditions data once at least
we succeeded to repair and not to be the
you know in the poorest conditions that
could be first the second we succeeded
to create a system that cares the people
in the terms of the health the medicine
treatments and which is absolutely
different that it really the council's
we reported last year that one jail
soraka prison no doctor had visited in
over a year this was last year
no doctor had been there in over a year
they had four medical orders orderlies
for 800 people you think that
satisfactory no of course it's not watch
that now fortunate already not on my
watch I left this is a report last year
28 my last I wasn't the Minister of
Justice 2017 yes we were but they're
already the minister at that time has
been transferred to a non-political
person and a technocrat since 2017 817
January in the position of the Minister
of Justice have been appointed only
technocrats the people with very
reliable and very trustful in a public
society and international community one
of them is an expert to nothing then
it's Commission and one of the
international community you read the
reports you see they don't trust
anything that's B there are issues it's
more than issues it's talking about
state commitments let's talk about
economical performance and social
performances and let's talk about those
reports because we focused on those area
and there are huge progresses in that
respect of course they're most
criticized the area's really she was in
jail who were living in conditions which
was said to be bordering on the
luxurious they had divan beds
kitchenettes fridges aquariums carpets
on the floor widescreen televisions so
somebody in your economy was doing well
it wasn't necessarily the poorest
section but these people in jail you
think that providing a sort of
for senior convicts and criminals known
as part of a double justice system and
as you said earlier last year European
standards what do you think in your talk
you have prisons like this no not at all
and let's go to the prisons to see and
to understand that I as I told you it is
a poor situation in the prisons but it
is much better than it was three years
ago and while talking about the people's
things as a report last year
yes but let's see the reports three
years ago and you will see a more poor
situation than the last year report and
year by year the reports are becoming
better and better nothing can be changed
all those good none of them a time when
you income not as why the point I made
at the beginning is you deserve to be
the good reports the good reports are in
the economical area in a social area
none of the questions have been received
so far from those area I understand that
more pleasant is to discuss everything
that could be criticized and we agree
with you that those are the areas that
have been performed poorly and couldn't
be better could be done better and they
are doing better but not in they with
the speed that we would like it to do
because it's not easy to do it is very
complicated to do the lots of effort has
been put in that respect
lots of the investments have been public
investments have been put it into that
area as well but still we have a lot of
things to do until everything will be
not perfect that acceptable and you're
going to work with this new government
even though you've already said it's
illegal you consider the coalition to be
illegal we said that it was illegal even
at the moment when we transfer the
governor's but we said but we said to
work what we said yes because we said at
that time you have to fix one deadlock
constitutional one and it has been fixed
and immediately as the Constitutional
Court has reversed some of its decisions
we said okay now we can enter in
to development now we can be in a
position real opposition and
constructive all right that image of
Atari thanks very much being on coming
here thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]